مشاهدينا في وقت تصنف الزلازل وموجات
التسونامي كافضع الكوارث هناك عوامل
طبيعيه اخرى لا تقل عنها خطوره وان كانت
نتيجتها ابطا مثل العواصف الترابيه سنتابع
هنا العواصف الترابيه تعني نقل الرياح
لجزيئات الغبار الدقيقه عبر الاف الاميال
وينبعث نحو مليارات من الرمل والغبار في
الغلاف الجوي سنويا بحسب الامم المتحده
انبعاثات تكلف منطقه الشرق الاوسط وشمال
افريقيا وحدها ثلاثه عشر مليار دولار
سنويا كما تسبب امراضا في الجهاز التنفسي
وتضر بالماشيه والمحاصيل وتعطل النقل
ويمكنها تسريع ظاهره الاحتباس الحراري ان
زادت وتييرتها غير ان وكاله الفضاء
الامريكيه ناسا تمكنت من رصد خطر العواصف
الترابيه في جميع انحاء العالم عبر جهاز
جديد عالي التقنيه يسمى اي ام اي تي اي
التحقيق في مصدر غبار سطح الارض المعدني
مقياس طيف التصوير الفضائي الاول من نوعه
يساعد في رسم الخرائط رسم خرائط الوان
الغبار وفهم تاثير غبار الصحراء على
المناخ كما يمكن العلماء بل يمكن العلماء
من استخدام البيانات الموجوده في نماذجهم
المناخيه لتحديد التركيب المعدني
والكيميائي للمواد الموجوده على السطح
وكذلك
انبعاثات المثال
الذي تم اطلاقه في يوليو العام الماضي
يتصل بمحطه الفضاء الدوليه ويدور حول
الارض 16 مره في اليوم يقوم ايضا بمسح
شرائط بعرض 50 ميلا خلال ثوان ما يزود
العلماء
بمليارات البيانات لاستخدامها في تنبؤات
النماذج المناخيه وفي وقت كانت مهمه اي ام
اي تي محدوده باثني عشر شهرا فقط هناك
حاليا خطط لتمديد هذه المهمه
[موسيقى]